we live in a 24-hour news cycle so much
breaking news it's hard to process at
all well is dumb and we found a way to
put the day's news in perspective with
the help of our good friend mr. Deon
Cole
[Music]
all right at the Republican debate last
night Donald Trump said he opposed
raising the minimum wage and claimed
were actually paying people too much the
down the Trump know what it's like to be
poor
I don't think so now his kids ever get
an IOU from the tooth fairy
I don't I don't think so did he make
fifteen million dollars sitting on his
rich orange ass telling people you fired
he did yeah then tell that racist Oompa
Loompa to shut the hell up
[Applause]
critics in other news critics say
presidential candidate ben Carson lied
in his autobiography when he said he was
offered a scholarship to West Point
doesn't everybody exaggerate sometimes
well yeah not everybody but yeah didn't
you just tell dissolving us we have a
great show tonight yeah I did yeah
and besides lyin isn't that ninety
percent of being a president yeah I
guess it kind of is yeah good tell all
those critters to me that crazy man
alone and shut the hell up
[Applause]
crazy good story people are criticizing
Jeb Bush because when a reporter asked
Jeb if he would go back in time would he
kill baby Hitler Bush replied hell yeah
I would does Jeb Bush want to be
President yes he does yeah and is having
George Bush as a brother ruining his
chances well yeah that's kind of what
they say so if Jed had a time machine
will he kill baby Hitler or baby George
oh god okay
then tell Jeb Bush the second
in other news the Navy's being
criticized for conducting missile tests
off the coast of California without
giving residents any warning hold on
hold on Conan I'm still stuck on this
time machine travel okay
okay Deion you're supposed to be
commenting on the news I know I am just
hit me about hear me out for a second
all right
I just just stop the damn dance stop the
damn dance stop it check it out if Jeb
Bush did go back in time to kill baby
Hitler there would be no World War two
right right right
which means Jess father would not have
been a war hero all right where you
going with this then no war hero
no presidency no bush dynasty so Jay
will have no chance of being president
so if you really think about it Jeb Bush
really needs baby Hitler more than
anyone beyond doing a favor let's just
get back to the news this is all crazily
hypothetical time travel is impossible
okay
physical is
anyway where was I
where was I oh yeah last week the Navy
conducted missile tests some people got
scared and thought they were UFOs so
naturally they were very upset the Navy
says they were actually did it cold in a
bit okay what have you done Deon I went
back in time I guess what I got I don't
know what you got baby
[Applause]
would you please please get baby Heather
please get baby Hitler Adi one last
thing one last thing and to everyone who
said I couldn't have been time travel
tell them they all need to shut
[Applause]
Pete always and gentlemen
tonight Academy Award nominee dr. author
of the new book bream give me hiccups
and other stories chessy Eisenberg is I
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]